>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Okay. Well, good afternoon
and thank you all for coming.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb.
I'm the Chief of the
African Middle East Division
and I'm delighted to
see you all here.
And so welcome.
Some of you are new.
Some of you have been
here many times before.
So before we start the program, let
me say something about our division.
We are the African and Middle East
Division and we include 78 countries
in terms of our responsibility.
Those 78 countries are about
the whole African continent,
North and Sub-Sahara and Africa.
We have the whole Middle
East that extends to --
from Morocco to Afghanistan.
We also include the
Near East section,
Central Asia, Armenia and Georgia.
And we have the Hebraic section
which also includes collections
that come from all over the
world to the collections.
Now the collections that
we are custodian of are
in the languages of those countries.
In other words, if you're
doing research on let's say,
today's topic on Lebanon, if you
were looking for sources in Arabic,
they would be part of
our collections here.
But if those sources on Lebanon were
in English, or French, or German,
or Greek or Italian, they would
be part of the general collection.
In other words, we
collect in the vernacular
and in the scripts
of those countries.
Our programs include --
so we collect and we serve
these materials to the audience.
But we also do exhibits and
we've had some major exhibits
in the past five years
on Afghanistan.
We've had one on the Hebrew book.
We had one on the Persian book.
We had one of the Armenian book.
And we're possibly trying now
to raise funds and have one
of the Arabic book and
on the African book.
We also have symposia and we bring
scholars from all over the world
to discuss various topics.
We just had two recently, one on
the ancient city of Tyre in Lebanon
and we had international
archaeologists, museum keepers,
curators, artists and
others come and participate.
And we had a Juneteenth symposium,
conference on the end of slavery
and again, it was -- we had
packed audiences in both cases.
So why are we all, why
are we doing these things?
We're doing this in order to
make our collections come alive.
We collect books and
we take care of them.
We preserve them.
We store them.
We serve them.
But we also want people to
understand how those cultures
and those societies
live, how they speak,
how they vote, how they write.
And it is through these programs,
through the scholars who come
and share with us the work they
have done, through film producers
as we have today, that we
make these cultures live.
Live in your imaginations,
in your thoughts.
We just had a wonderful program on
Ethiopia with someone who had gone
to Ethiopia and had filmed
and taken photographs
of the beautiful topography
of Ethiopia,
the mountains, the
lakes, the fields.
So in this way, those of us who are
lucky enough to be present, live --
leave this one-hour presentation
enriched and more knowledgeable
than when they first
came to the Library.
We are also addressing people
outside of the Library,
across the world because since
we are webcasting our programs,
people from every continent
in the world can have access
to these programs and
see them and learn
about the programs we're doing.
So now, I would like to introduce
our Arab Word Specialist,
Dr. Muhannad Salhi, a historian,
a graduate from the University
of Chicago and the person who
has organized today's event.
I want to say a couple of
words also about our specialist
in all our three sections,
the African,
the Near East, and
the Hebraic section.
They're all scholars themselves.
They have written.
They have published.
They are quoted in books.
And they know the society
and the culture
and the languages of the region.
So our scholar, Dr. Muhannad
Salhi, will introduce the speaker
and the film producer
today, Muhannad.
>> Our speaker today and
documentary filmmaker,
I should say, is Rouane Itani.
She is a Lebanese-American filmmaker
based in Washington, DC, a local.
And Ms. Itani started her media
career in broadcast TV in Beirut,
Lebanon before coming to the United
States where she earned her MA
in Film and Video Producing.
She runs a boutique media
production company, Aflama LLC,
and has several years of experience
creating corporate documentary
and educational projects.
She is fluent in Arabic,
French and English.
Madame Parliamentarian , the
movie we are about to see --
or documentary, I should say,
that we are about to see is
her first independent film.
So without further
ado, Rouane Itani.
>> Rouane Itani: Hello, I
would like to thank Mary-Jane
and Dr. Muhannad Salhi from the
Near East section of the African
and Middle Eastern Division
of the Library of Congress
for organizing this event
and inviting me here today.
And thank you all for being
here for this hour together.
Just a few words about
the documentary film
that we're going to be seeing.
It's short, 16 minutes and its
entitled "Madame Parliamentarian".
Just to give you a general context,
I usually like to take Q and A's
after the film but just to
give you a general setting,
it was filmed during two
- the last two elections
of Lebanon, 2005 and 2009.
And it focuses on the participation
of women in the Lebanese parliament.
I'll just say a couple of things
about the general political
or parliamentarian
system in Lebanon.
In general, Lebanon is
-- population consist
of we just say roughly
50% Christian, 50% Muslim
and the distribution of the seats
in the Lebanese parliament
try to reflect that.
So the way the seats are identified
or located follow a religious quota
in a way so though the
terms confessionalism
or sectarianism will be mentioned
a couple of times in the film
and probably by me
in the Q and A after
and that's what these
terms refer to.
I know that for some people in
the United States or other places,
they might not be familiar with the
term confessionalism or sectarianism
and that's what it refers to.
It's basically how the parliament,
the seats in the parliament
have certain quotas
to reflect the religious diversity
of the population in Lebanon.
I think I'll leave it at that
for now and watch the film
and we can discuss later.
Thank you.
[ Inaudible Video Playing ]
Just again, to get -- to
give a little bit more
about the political structure
and the demographic structure.
To make sense for people who don't
know that under the Christian
and the Muslim populations,
the makeup of a country,
there are 17 religious sects.
So there are various churches and
various divisions of denominations
of Islam, Sunni, Shia and a
third minority which is Druze.
And under Christians, there are
majority Maronite Catholics,
East Orthodox, Greek
Orthodox, Catholic Orthodox,
there are various churches
and two Armenian churches.
So depending on which zones
or districts in the country,
the populations distribution
there, in some populations
in some districts, let's say, the
population might be more homogenous
in terms of the religious makeup.
And in that -- in those districts,
for instance, in terms of quota,
there might be maybe four seats
for the same religious group
allocated for the parliament.
So that the people in that district,
the electors will be voting
for when they get a list, an
electoral list to vote for.
They actually see the names
of the candidates and next
to them are the religious
affiliation
and then they have several
by specific religious
denomination depending on the makeup
of the population within
that district.
So that's kind of how it works so it
gives you a little bit of a sense.
All right, let's take questions.
>> Thank you very much.
It was wonderful.
I've always wondered.
I had always the same question.
Why is it that in Lebanon,
the women are so free
in so many different ways, why are
they not represented in parliament?
So I think you're addressing
the issue right on [inaudible].
My question is the issue of money.
They bring this up again and again.
But women in Lebanon are
just as wealthy as men.
In other words, the money that
goes to support the men who are
into a position, into
the electorate, okay,
can very well be used for a woman.
In other words, why is the
issue of money being brought
in when [inaudible] very
wealthy woman [inaudible].
So why is the money issue an issue?
>> Rouane Itani: Okay, the stakes --
it's really one of the core
questions which comes at the end
of the film as a main question.
So it's a very important
piece of the puzzle.
And there are various
ways to address this.
If we cannot go through
the [inaudible] --
the kind of the chronology of
the history from what you've seen
in the film, the 10 women who
have ever entered parliament,
nine of that -- well, we all, many
of them, nine of them actually,
have come in because of the
man in their family who was
in the parliament or very close to
power, political power before them
and they've just kind of filled
in the seat of their father,
brother, et cetera, husband.
So there's that one layer that
the women in the first place,
they're not running
independently and getting in.
That's also a problem for men too.
So it's both, it's
everybody that there is kind
of the Lebanese phenomenon.
There is that aspect of clanship
or wealthy families who have been
in power in the past who keep kind
of coming back again and again
and recycling the same family names.
So the women's representation
is falling under some
of those situations also.
And one of the issues
here is looking
into why aren't there independent
women in the first place?
And then we can talk about -- yes,
why aren't there independent women
who are not made part of that whole
general political party blocs,
the major blocs that have the powers
in the country and those that are
within the system, yet, why
aren't they even running?
Because there's not
enough women running also.
So it's multilayered,
it's not just the capital.
A few years ago, actually, when I
first filmed in 2005, the media,
the access to media to cover a
woman's candidate wasn't equivalent.
They were giving access to men and
they were lumping all the women
in kind of like a side bar.
Then there was a change in that law.
So now the last I know is that
there is equality of media access
so both men and women candidates
have equal access to show 50%
of like so that's when men and
women can have access to the media
to cover their campaigns
when they're running.
So that's an improvement.
So there was one [inaudible],
the question of budget was coming
into that it require a lot of
money to buy media spots or access
to the media to publicize oneself
and to run a campaign in general.
Women have been found to be
campaign managers for men.
But it's kind of like the whole
structure hasn't been created enough
at least yet for women
candidates to figure out how
to channel all not just the money
but the support, the mechanism,
the whole structure of campaigning
and promoting themselves.
So there's all of that.
In addition, the question
of access to money
for women might be a little
complex because there are women
who are independent and are wealthy.
We don't again, some of these
wealthy women, are they wealthy
because they come from that
wealthy family clan system
that has been in power.
Again, so they're still
not regular independent --
when I say independent meaning
like not part of that kind
of political power structure.
If they're coming from that,
their money probably
came through that family.
There is also a lot of
social pressure sometimes
from within the family that if a
woman comes up and they say, "Why,
is there a shortage
of men in our family?
Like why is the woman
going to take that money?"
So there are multiple,
multiple questions
and I think it's a little
bit more challenging
than just simply a woman
saying, "I have all this money.
I'm just going to run."
It's multi-layered and that would be
maybe a topic for another film to go
and see, talk to a wealthy
woman and say, "You know,
why aren't you putting your
money in a future campaign?"
But that -- thank you,
that's a very good question.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
So like I said, some of those
interviews, they were 2005 and 2009
which were the last elections
fortunately that have happened.
Another set of elections was
supposed to happen in 2013.
Every four years is when
the election was due.
But you, because of what's been
going on in the region with Syria
and all the problems, the
elections have -- are still on hold.
So imagine, since post-war
Lebanon which is 1991 until 2009,
there were elections
every four years.
And now the last ones were 2009
which is really a long time.
So some of what you're hearing
is from those years before
and now the question is
how have things changed,
if there is an election in 2017
which is the next one that's kind
of they're hoping that would happen.
And what -- at the time, what people
meant was that the media coverage,
not the -- so there is access
of women to the media meaning
if the women want to put their own
spots and promotional campaign,
you know, spots and
promotions, they have to just --
they have to pay but
also that now both men
and women can access it equally.
The coverage was that media
people themselves like, the news,
and producers, and news media, when
they're trying to cover the news
or follow the candidates.
They would take the male
candidates and cover them thoroughly
about who this person is, where they
come from, what their ideas are,
et cetera and go on in
depth as one candidate meant
and then they would lump all
the women candidates as --
and here are the women as just like
these are just women candidates.
But we don't know who they are
really or what they stand for,
what they're running for.
And that's what they're
referring to.
>> And so [inaudible], people
will also [inaudible] air time
covering it?
>> Rouane Itani: I believe so, yeah.
>> Then why isn't [inaudible]?
>> Rouane Itani: That's
what I understand, yeah.
I don't know the depth of the law
but that's my understanding is
that it, the media should now allow
equal access on the air for male
and female so that they cannot be
covering males more extensively
and just spending three minutes
on all the women candidates.
Yes?
>> Hi, I just have a
question [inaudible].
I just have a question on
some of the information
because I'm interested in the film
to say Lebanon is 50-50
Christian and Muslim?
But when you showed the graph
of the different sectarian
percentages in the film, it wasn't.
It was Muslim larger,
Christian maybe 40%,
22% so the Christians are just
broken down into all the, you know,
professions that we talked about.
>> Rouane Itani: Are you referring
to the maps or the [inaudible]?
>> Well, yes and the [inaudible]
that was 100%, 100% for [inaudible].
>> Rouane Itani: I think you may
be referring in the pie charts
to there is a quote, there are a
couple of things going on there.
There is a proposal about
having 30%, a quota for women,
to be 30% of the parliament.
So there is that one reference
and this is a percentage
that was recommended during
the Beijing Women's --
International Women's Conference and
this is a percentage that is sought
after in many countries
around the world.
So even including right now,
several European countries
have implemented that.
Several African countries
That's following those Beijing
recommendations is what the world is
kind of moving towards.
And in Lebanon, there has been these
efforts by the woman's movement
to try to ask for that but there
is a pushback from the last --
the parliament refusing
that and there is --
that's kind of if you
want updated information.
That last number of years,
that's what's happening
that the women's movement has had
to work with the parliamentarians --
the majority male that
represented parliamentary Lebanon
and negotiate how they can
have more representation
of women in the parliament.
The parliament has rejected,
has voted down twice the request
to have 30% so that's not
going to happen anytime soon.
It doesn't look like it.
So now then, there were
conversations about,
okay, can we have 20%?
Can we have 10%, and now
there are other discussions
about possibly having what they
call a zippered electoral list
or candidates list.
Which means that when the next
elections would happen that people
when they vote, they will see a
list with names of male and female,
men and women candidates so every
other one will be like male, woman,
man, woman, man, woman, man, woman.
That's what they call
a zippered list.
Tunisia, I believe,
is implementing that.
Many other places are and it
seems to be a good kind of way
of showing equally that for the
electoral, for the electorate to see
that you have both names
available there available for you.
And that's still being discussed.
Another discussion has been okay,
forget about the 30% of seats
that would be set up in
the parliament for women.
Can we have 30% or something
along those lines on the list?
So and when you see the name
of the [inaudible] candidates,
you're not seeing all men,
that we need to have more
women on those lists.
And so these aren't some
of the proposals that have,
are being still discussed
behind closed doors or you know,
still kind of ongoing right now.
>> So I wasn't going
to that actually.
I was referring to the [inaudible].
>> Rouane Itani: Oh,
I'll try to repeat.
>> Could you [inaudible]?
>> Rouane Itani: So I think the
question was about some of the maps
and references to religious
distribution in the country.
So I'll just try and clarify.
The last census that was
officially done in Lebanon was 1932
and now people who have to,
who use you know, the census
and that information, they
still go back and refer to that
which at the time generally --
roughly speaking was 50%
Christian, 50% Muslim.
And the reason those numbers are
important is because what I --
what you've seen, what I've
explained is that the seats
in the parliament try to reflect
the demographics of the country.
At the end of the civil war,
the Lebanese civil war in 1991,
there was a change in the
parliament distribution.
They increased the
number of [inaudible] --
members of parliament to 128.
It was less before.
It was close to a hundred and
they made now the distribution
of the seats in the parliament,
50% Christian, 50% Muslim.
So in a way, now the
parliament is more equitable,
if you usually, if
we want to say that.
While before there were issues and
that's what people thought about,
you know, is one group being
represented more than the other,
has more power than
the other, et cetera.
And it's hard right now to
know exact numbers of figures
of what the demographic
ridges and sects are
because there is no
official census being made.
So some of these graphs in
the film, some of them were
from a number of years ago.
We don't know -- I don't know if
anybody has a map or a distribution
that is by any means
official or definitive.
So these are all, you
know, roughly depending
on what source they came from,
who made those estimates.
There more estimates, I would say.
And also, because the distribution
of these religious
groups varies depending
on sector -- sections
of the country.
And there is also the issue
of migration and a lot
of displacement due to the Lebanese
civil war and other problems
where a lot of, there were a lot
of displaced refugees that moved
from neighborhood, or part of the
country, or region to the other.
So it's really complicated
to figure out, you know,
what is the real religious
distribution
or the sectarian distribution.
And so that's kind
of the larger issue.
Yes?
>> I was wondering what the 30%
rate is because as you mentioned,
you know, the Lebanon's
political system is [inaudible].
Is one of the [inaudible]
representatives [inaudible]
that perhaps overburdened
by also [inaudible].
Is that also one of the [inaudible]?
>> Rouane Itani: Absolutely,
so I'll kind of re-answer
with including the question
because that's exactly the fact.
The reason why the parliament
has rejected twice that proposal
of asked of by the
women's movement --
to ask to have 30% of the seats
in parliament to be women.
The arguments that
come back with no,
are that we already have all
this complicated religious quota
that we have to deal
with, with the candidates
and the seat distribution,
how can we add on top
of that another quota for women?
That it would make impossible
and very complicated.
So that is -- that's exactly one.
Now the issue of quota is very
controversial issue in probably
in many countries but all
very much so in Lebanon.
And even the word the term quota is
controversial and very polarizing
and people have a strong
reaction to that term quota.
So as the years went by, now the
women's movement has started not --
trying not to even use the
term quota because it divides
and polarizes people so
badly like for and against.
Some of the women themselves
are against that idea of quota
because they feel that it is,
it is discriminatory in itself.
It's as if women are not qualified
or strong or equal or ready.
It's kind of like why do we need
to be handed out special treatment?
We don't need to be given seats.
We can do it on our own.
So there's some of that, that
is being said by certain women.
And because by law, from the
beginning of the independence
of the country, the constitution
gives equal rights to men and women
to vote, to run, so
there is nothing legally
that is stopping a
woman from running.
I mean, in terms of voting, there
is no problem because women vote,
so women do go and they vote
and the number of voters
of women is maybe not 50% but it's
definitely more than 40% according
to the last general surveys
that happened in 2009.
So it's not a shortage
of women voters
and there are various organizations
that have been working very strongly
on promoting and encouraging
women to vote in more numbers
and giving them ID cards and
all of the support to vote.
So the problem is not on the
voting, it's more on the running --
on really women presenting
themselves.
And I'll just add a couple of
updates because the film was,
you know, from those years
back that there are two
or three major organisms
in the country independent
from the government
but also a couple
of semi-governmental
organizations that have been working
with women candidates
creating leadership training,
encouraging women to run.
Training them on how to run a
campaign, how to do public speaking,
how to fund raise, all of that.
And in 2009, the number of
women candidates were only 12.
So there were only 12 women
who ran for parliament in 2009
and four of those got in.
And the last I know which
was a couple of years --
2013 when there was supposed to be
an election, there were up to 40,
four-zero candidates,
women candidates.
And this is believed
to be due to the fact
of having organizations now
systematically working with women
in a kind of a more organized
way around different districts
to bring more women
candidates to the front
to prepare them, to get them there.
So it's starting to become
more hopeful for women
to show that we are there.
Because another argument
from the parliament was
that well, there are no women.
There are no women candidates.
There are not enough women
who want to be running.
That's why we can't give them quotas
because who are we
going to put in there?
And now the response from the
women's organizations is to show no,
we have 40 candidates right now
and it could be much more if we go,
if we go on so that's
kind of this part.
Yes? Sorry.
I don't know how much time we have.
Go ahead.
>> [Inaudible] 10 minutes.
>> [Inaudible] to the issues
that the woman's [inaudible].
>> Rouane Itani: Ah!
>> And it's something beyond
just having women [inaudible].
>> Rouane Itani: Yes.
So the question is are there
specific women's issues
that women would like --
>> They're not just issues.
That it's not --
>> Rouane Itani: -- or issues or
specific issues that people would
like for women candidates
to raise in parliament.
I think that that's the question.
I'll mention in terms of women's
issues that and that is a problem
by itself, what I'm just going
to say which is women don't --
women candidates don't
want to be [inaudible] --
cannot be pigeon-holed in that
you're going to become a woman,
a parliamentarian to promote or
to lobby for women's causes only.
You should be seen as a
woman candidate like any --
like the man, just anybody and be
interested in any political platform
or issues then topics that you
want to focus on and work on.
So there is that, that first
fight to just look at women
as a normal politician and not
expect them any special service,
or treatment, or focus
on any issues.
In addition to that, of course,
the women's movement wants men
and women candidates in the
parliament to fix the laws
that are affecting women's status
in the country so it's kind
of like a two-side approach.
And the main issues for
the women's movement
in general are there are still
laws that are unjust for in regards
to domestic violence and
sexual rape, domestic rape,
like that domestic -- so
domestic violence and harassment,
things along those lines.
And there is a big one
which is about citizenship.
Right now, Lebanese women who marry
a non-Lebanese man cannot give their
citizenship to the man nor to
their children who are born --
who could be born and
could be living in Lebanon.
So that passing of
citizenship from a woman
to her family is right now absent.
It's always been absent.
While a man can very simply marry
a foreign woman give her Lebanese
citizenship and the children,
of course, will be born
and because he is a male father,
he could pass on his citizenship.
So these are like the main
two big issues that in terms
of women's rights are being
by parliament to be adjusted.
Did I see -- yeah, someone
here had another question?
Oh, go ahead.
>> I thought I heard it mentioned
in the film, some suggested an end
of the confessional system?
Was that anything on that?
I don't hear any that it's really
the end of discussion at all.
>> Rouane Itani: That's
kind of like a side topic.
I'm not sure if somebody may
have mentioned it briefly.
That's a whole other
issue that I would say,
it's kind of off-topic in a way.
Yes, there is -- it's something
that, it's a hot potato in Lebanon
and people discuss it but
it's, I will leave it at that.
It's kind of a side bar.
Yes?
>> Can [inaudible] be less?
How many Lebanese women
work outside the home?
>> Rouane Itani: Oh,
work outside the home.
I was going to say for the political
representation, Lebanon is the less
than -- it's like 3% in [inaudible]
-- in the parliament and here,
I believe in Congress,
it's reached 12% so even
in the U.S., it's not that high.
It's only around 12% of women
are in Congress while Rwanda,
the last I know, used to be the
number one country in the world
that had the highest number
of women in their parliament.
So you think, you know, women --
well, Rwanda has the highest
number of women in parliament.
The U.S. has only 12%.
A number of countries in Europe
have very close to 50% or 40 --
30 to 40% or somewhere
around that number.
But I don't know the answer
to again about percentages.
I just, would just
estimate kind of offhand
that it's a high percentage,
more than 30%.
I would say 30 to 50% of
women work outside the home.
I guess that's the question, right?
>> The reason why I asked
this is because previously,
[inaudible] women working
outside the home, they [inaudible]
and so they got their
own [inaudible].
And also, they might have
felt some way to give it away
or spend it the way their
fathers or husbands would resent.
And so, are they changed for women?
Can they support facts like
office sidelines or in this list,
support by government really but
women are making their own money
and so they feel freer maybe in
balance of power within the family
to be more of an equal partner
[inaudible] to decision making.
>> Rouane Itani: So do I need
to repeat, summarize some
of that for the [inaudible]?
So I believe what you
mentioned was that in the U.S.,
as more women started
working outside the home,
they gained more independence
financially
to use their money as they wished.
While at the beginning, maybe
as they were starting to work,
they were getting their money more
either through family inheritance
or through the men or
getting them later in life.
And they felt that they were
obliged to spend that money in a way
that would please the
males and their family.
And so as more women
have independence,
financial independence,
how to use their,
gain and use their own money then
they have more freedom to do that.
And I would say that would,
is probably very correct,
very applicable to Lebanon also.
Right now, there are women who are
bank presidents, business owners,
pilots, airplane pilots,
tons of architects,
40% of the judges are women,
engineers, tech people.
You know, they're there.
But I guess, that's another
film that we need to do to get
to answer that -- that part.
Do we still have time?
I don't know.
I have one or two last questions?
Yes?
>> I was curious how the film is
being introduced to [inaudible],
you know, where in Lebanon?
I'm just curious about that.
>> Rouane Itani: So when I
made the film, as you see,
I made it in English even though
there is an Arabic subtitled version
and a French subtitled
version so it could be shown.
It has been shown in Lebanon and
a couple of places, high schools
and it was well received.
And there was a discussion
with the Ministry of Education
and some organizations that
work on education to figure
if it could be used in the
school, in the educational system.
So that could possibly
happen in the future.
But I think my original plan was to
just bring awareness to the issue,
to kind of shed light on the
status of women in Lebanon.
Because I feel that especially,
that I live here like in the U.S.,
there are a lot of
misconceptions about women
in the Middle East overall and
they think that women are much --
I don't have less, much less
rights than they actually do.
And to show that at least in this
particular story for the case
of Lebanon and in this particular
subject that women are there.
They have obstacles
but they're there.
So I thought this would give
a general sense to audience,
to international audiences
about the status
of women in Lebanon in general.
And it's been -- it's
shown in a few festivals
and at various organizations,
independent screenings.
And I would hope that I, we
could still show it more widely
around the world and
with more organizations
or educational systems.
So if you have suggestions
for groups
who might be interested,
I'd be open to that.
And then the website is
www.madameparliamentarian.com
so it's the name of the film.com.
You can find more information and
the film is available for sale
on DVD and [inaudible]
streaming from the website and --
I don't know what else I can say.
Is that [applause]
-- oh my time is up?
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.